With this kind of star network in particular,
the datastructure that you need to set up is
actually quite simple. We need to be able to compute
the distance between any pair of nodes
called say a which is labelled here in the graph, and b labelled here in the graph
and they have to have lists of hubs such that
the uh... the hub has to be on a shortest path from a to b,
well all the paths from a to b
in fact all the paths between anything in the network have to pass through x
so as long as everybody has their distance to x
which is 1 if it's an unweighed network but there could be weights on these edges
as long as each node knows its distance to x
we'll be able to intersect the lists
for any pair of nodes and know the total distance
from node a to node b.
uh... one little bit of trickiness there though is that
notice that x's list also has to have x on it
but that's ok. It can just have x with
a distance of zero so it can be its own hub
and then we still should be fine we'll
get the distance from a to x
which is whatever the distance from a
to x is plus zero so one is the
answer I was looking for.